- [Instructor] So I have
an uncompressed spring here
and the spring has a spring constant
of four Newtons per meter.
Then I take a 10 gram
mass, a 10 gram ball,
and I put it at the top of
the spring and I push down
to compress that spring by 10 centimeters.
And so let's call that
scenario one right over there,
where our mass is on top
of this compressed spring.
And then let's say, we let go.
And then the spring launches
this mass into the air,
and then this mass is gonna
hit some maximum height.
And let's call that scenario two
when we are hitting that maximum height.
And my question to you is,
what is that maximum height
based on all of the information
that I have given you here?
And I'll give you a hint.
What we have to think about is the idea
that energy is conserved.
The total energy in scenario
one is gonna be equal
to the total energy in scenario two.
So pause this video and
see if you can figure out
what that maximum height is going to be.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
I told you that the total
energy is gonna be conserved,
but what's that total energy
going to be made up of?
Well, it's gonna have
some potential energy
and it's going to have
some kinetic energy.
And so another way to think about it is,
our potential energy in scenario one
plus our kinetic energy in scenario one
needs to be equal to our
potential energy in scenario two,
plus our kinetic energy in scenario two.
And there might be other energies here
that you could think
about heat due to friction
with the air, but we're not going to,
we're going to ignore those
to just simplify the problem.
We can assume that this
is happening in a vacuum,
that might help us a little bit.
So if we think about
the potential energies,
there's actually two types of
potential energies at play.
There's gravitational potential energy,
and there is elastic potential energy
due to the fact that this mass is sitting
on a compressed spring.
So our gravitational potential energy
is going to be our mass times the strength
of our gravitational field,
times our height in position one,
and our elastic potential energy
is going to be equal to one
half times our spring constant,
times how much that spring
is compressed, squared.
And so this is all of our
potential energy in scenario one,
right over here.
And then we add our kinetic energy.
So plus, we have one half times our mass,
times our velocity in
scenario one, squared.
And so the sum of this is gonna be the sum
of all of this in scenario two.
And so that is going to
be equal to mass times G
times height in scenario two,
plus one half times our spring constant
times how much that's spring is compressed
in scenario two squared,
plus one half times our mass,
times our velocity in
scenario two, squared.
And just as a reminder, what
we have right over here,
this is our potential
energy in scenario two.
And then our kinetic
energy is right over there.
Now this might look
really hairy and daunting,
but there's a lot of simplification here.
We can define our starting
point right over here,
H one as being equal to zero,
which will simplify this dramatically.
Cause if H one is zero, then
this term right over here,
zero, we also know that
our velocity is zero
in our starting scenario.
So that would make our
kinetic energy zero.
So the left-hand side is really
all about our elastic potential energy.
So it's gonna be one half
times our spring constant,
times how much we have
compressed the spring
in scenario one, squared.
And then on the right-hand
side, what's going on?
Well, in this scenario, our
spring is no longer compressed.
So our elastic potential
energy is now zero.
And what about our kinetic energy?
Well, at maximum height right over here,
your ball is actually
stationary for an instant,
for a moment.
It's right at that
moment where it is going
from moving up to starting to move down.
And so our velocity is
actually zero right over here.
So V2 is actually zero,
just like V1 was zero.
So that's gonna be zero.
And so you have a scenario
where our initial elastic
potential energy is going to
be equal to our scenario two,
gravitational potential energy.
And so we just need to solve
for this right over here.
That is going to be our maximum height.
To do that, we can divide both sides by mg
and we get h2 is equal to
1/2 k delta x, one squared,
all of that over mg.
And we know what all of these things are,
and I'll write it out with the units.
This is going to be equal to one half
times our spring constant,
which is four Newtons per meter.
Now our change in x is 10 centimeters,
but we have to be very careful.
We can't just put a 10 centimeters
here and then square it.
We want the units to match up.
So we're not dealing with
centimeters and grams.
We're dealing with meters and kilograms.
So I wanna convert this
10 centimeters to meters.
Well, that's gonna be 0.1 meters.
So I will write this as times 0.1.
That's how much the spring is compressed.
That's our delta x in terms of meters.
And so that is gonna be squared.
And then all of that
over, what is our mass?
And once again, we want
to express our mass
in terms of kilograms.
So our mass is 0.01 kilograms.
G is 9.8 meters per second squared.
And when you calculate it, this
is approximately 0.2 meters.
And the units actually all do work out.
Because if you look at
Newtons as being the same
as kilogram meters per second squared,
this kilograms cancels with
that kilograms right over there.
You can see that this per second squared
is gonna cancel with
that per second squared
right over there.
And then this meter is going
to cancel out with that meter.
And so what you're left
with is a meter squared
divided by meters,
which is just going to
leave you with meters,
just like that.
And we're done.
We figured out the maximum
height using just our knowledge
of the conservation of energy
is approximately 0.2 meters.